first of all let me start with
congratulations on the doc I thought it
was so well done uh but before we jump
into that uh I have a ton of questions
um if someone and I hopefully you'll
find some of these at least
semi-entertaining or enjoyable
um if someone has actually never seen
anything you've directed before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
I think I want them to watch bertoluccio
and Bertolucci because I think that that
movie encompasses in a quite precise way
what I feel it's an act of love
of loving and of loving Cinema
and understanding the power of the
conversation and the power of listening
and the power of Psych analysis I think
that is one of my most accomplished
works if you could and I know people
want to make projects with you but if
you get the financing to make anything
you want uh what would you make and why
I'm not I'm not a big fan of like
unlimited resources I think that's a
little bit for the insecure people uh so
I'm not really into uh like
um looking for a project that can be
done extravagantly in terms of the of
the costs uh and I actually feel that
I've been doing everything I wanted to
do and in a very personal way always
including my last movie Challengers
still to be finished but almost done
um
I I I I think I'd like to I'd like to
I'd like to build more worlds in my life
I'd like to create more more worlds with
my with my imagination and with the work
with the help of great writers and great
actors that I work with constantly I'd
like to make a musical and I'd like to
make an animation film those are the two
things that I'd really love to make I'm
very curious about both of those coming
out of your mind
um I will not I hope those both happen
um what do you I'd like to make I'd like
to make a that's that I can tell because
it's true
I'd like to make like a movie that gets
the young version of meat of today to be
like Speed Racing hard
like the way I did have that feeling
watching Richard Donner's Superman so
I'd like to make a Superman for today to
have that kind of like beautiful feeling
that the donor movie had I don't know if
they have room for that at DC but that's
what I would love to do I this was not
what I was going to ask you but how are
you interested the the the superhero
genre is is definitely the most popular
genre on the planet it is what the a lot
of the audience loves going to see these
is making a superhero movie something
you're interested in or not at all well
I would like to make if I could movies
in which I have complete control on the
story on the characters on the
production on the cut
and I do not believe that there are
things that cannot be said
I think that it's it's a how you say it
but the point being that uh um if
someone who has the power to make me do
a movie like that would allow me to have
that kind of control then I would
consider it very surely you have
something behind it I love a gold rake
love it
oh you uh these up here oh my God yeah
yeah those I I grew up with those uh
robots uh it's a big deal to me for me
for me too I'm still wondering one of
the reasons I have these behind me is
because it's great IP that no one is
making you know grandizer and Guy King
and battle of the planets and all of
these things that I love
um that now with modern VFX you can
probably do
clue through that's true they tried in
the in the early 90s was very bad yeah
well the visual effects industry was not
what it is today you you it was too
early just like Robotech or Star Blazers
there's all these properties that I love
but that's a whole separate thing
um if which of your projects changed the
most in the editing room in ways you did
not expect
probably my first movie the protagonist
which I had very big Ambitions for and
eventually I fall flat on my face
because I didn't control my work and I
didn't know what love that I wanted to
do that for sure and certainly Melissa P
that I
went on doing in a way that I thought I
was in control and I did have control
but then the such control was taken off
my hands by the studio and that was a
very bitter experience you've made if
I'm I could be wrong but I believe
you've made 12 documentaries
um uh when how do you know when you want
to actually make one of them where you
feel compelled I need to tell this story
I want to make documentaries always like
always I am now making a documentary
since four years almost on uh the state
of exception in France and Europe uh
after the uh massacres at the in Paris
and the bataclan
I've been interviewing these luminaries
these incredible thinkers
about the concept of the state of
exception
which is something that Americans knows
very well given guantana more given
everything that you had got through from
uh the first uh Desert Storm onward
um but I have not been able to conclude
it because of the copy in the first
place and then a lot of work on other
stuff
but it's something that I've been
working for a long time
I I always want to make documentaries
always does this project you just
mentioned does it have a title yes it's
called intimacy got it you did an ad
back in 2013. I believe it was called
Walking stories
which I adore
well my question is was that your first
did that ad sort of lead to this
documentary was that like like an
opening of the door if you will somehow
because I've been working for this this
short film fashion film and I've been
shooting in Florence and I remember that
I I where I was staying in a hotel that
was owned by the family Ferragamo and
while we were shooting and there was in
the in the rooms in the Hotel this book
called Shoemaker of Dreams
and I was curious about it and I got a
copy and I I remember we were shooting
the short film in in Florence Los
Angeles and Hong Kong
and we were really doing it in five days
so we were flying a lot flying shooting
flying shooting so what I did
I lost a sense of time and I lost sense
of uh sleep and I started to read the
book then
and I loved it well his story is
incredible and I one of the things that
I had no idea of which you shine a light
on in the documentary is what he was
doing at age 10 and 12. it's crazy
when he when he was 17 what he was doing
and when I was 10 I was playing with
toys you know he can you sort of talk
about his life is so unusual
well I think that Salvatore Ferragamo
literally is one of a kind it's like
that that Rarity that rather rare person
that has a sort of
like
is is being born with a mission that
transcends him and has to be
accomplished
and uh he's a genius
and he is someone who kind of probably
have found a way to reconcile
the rigor of of the mission he has put
himself upon to and
wonderment that he had to preserve in
order to continue finding things because
the way in which he lived his life from
the age of five onward was in in the
discipline of making and in the
wonderment of Discovery constant
that's why probably died so young
because probably his body couldn't carry
the intensity of his personality I don't
know the more I research the more I
watch from your film The More I
researched them I mean it it's you know
he was almost like the Michelangelo of
shoes you know somehow that's correct
and it's it's quite accurate yeah the
level of invention and also what
happened with the car accident and what
he did and it's incredible yeah
agreed
um so talk a little bit about one of the
things you've got Scorsese in the movie
did you know that he was knowledgeable
about
um you know the shoes and everything
else or how did that come about well my
idea to to invite Marty to be in the
movie was that because he was he is such
a great expert and and has this kind of
incredible literate qualities about the
history of Hollywood and because the
history of Hollywood cause is crossed
over by the experience of Ferragamo in
that system we felt it was a great idea
to have ask him to navigate us through
what meant to be in Hollywood at the
time and what to Hollywood was at the
time
and he was so gracious and he was so
committed I think he took the time to to
study Salvatore as well so he could tell
us things about Hollywood but also put
in that perspective Salvatore Ferragamo
it was wonderful was one of the Great
Moments of my filming career to film
this course has doing this great I can't
even imagine
um one of the cool things is that you
got to use his actual voice in some of
the Home Movies when did you find out
that you had access to that and actually
had his voice that you could use
well I I had the
um read the book and then I spoke to the
guy to the family Ferragamo and I asked
them access to their foundation and
their Museum and I discovered like a
trove of frasures including a lot of uh
tapes with the voice of Salvatore
Ferragamo and the Super 8 movies that
Sarah Ferragamo shot since he was like
in his late 20s
um and I discovered this voice
pretty soon and that became one of the
backbones of the structure that with
Tana Thomas the writer and with the with
the Walter Fasano the editor we decided
to go for
um talk a little bit about putting
together the film in the editing room
because obviously I'm sure you had a ton
of footage
did you how did you decide on the length
and was it almost uh like a longer movie
well no I think there was a lot of
material we had to regretfully lose a
lot and when we did it present the movie
in Venice it was a bit longer and there
was a lot a lot of hinging a lot and um
on the emotional stories from younger
members of the family and then
afterwards I reviewed the movie again
with the Walter and I realized that
probably to tame that down a little bit
more would have been best and now the
evolution you saw is the version that
came out off
after benetti and before the actual
release in America eventually this will
be out on home video you know there'll
be DVD or Blu-ray do you have a lot of
extras that you're putting on like any
extra footage I don't I we have not put
our minds on it yet but I I can promise
you that we will definitely
um before I run out of time with you uh
you know I'm a fan of your work what was
it about
um Challengers that said I want to make
this movie many elements at the great
script from the from Justin kuritzkas
sexy and fun and never done something
like that
um working with Amy Pascal who I adore
who I feel I'm respectfully to her
wonderful husband I feel married with
and uh and then they uh of course she's
just inspiring and and and Sublime so
there were so many great elements that
could I couldn't say no basically I was
like I have to say yes I'm not sure
you've wrapped filming where are you in
the production process I am starting mix
early December okay so you're almost
done yeah yeah one of the things I
really enjoyed Mike's work in West Side
Story was that right what was that did
you see him in that and say oh I want
him in challenges yeah when do you think
people might get their first look at a
trailer or footage
MGM
that I think they love the movie so
we'll see
um so I definitely want to know uh you
you were rumored to do bride's head
Revisited was that I wasn't rumored I
wanted to make it we couldn't make we
couldn't put together the entire budget
that needed for it but we really wanted
to make it
um and what about uh pardon me for just
peppering you with questions but what
happened uh is your job yes
um but I read that there was a biopic uh
for Aubry Heparin uh for apple with uh
Rooney Mara maybe playing the role is
there is that true is it not true I
found very interesting that every time
uh often there is like a really a leak
or a release on what I'm doing I work a
lot and I love to develop a lot and I
love I work I love to find projects and
um
uh and Rooney is one of the greatest
actresses of her generation and I would
be flattered towards that's what I can
say right so do you know what you
actually are gonna do next or are you
picking between projects I'm producing
their Columbia gasoline new movie
the great director from of beginning
I am now we're almost done with this
great filmmaker from Italy called Pietro
castelito who is directing his second
feature that I'm producing
and
um I I'm producing a lot and hopefully
I'm gonna finalize the shooting I need
to complete conclude for
um intimacy my document before I run out
of time with you uh I as I said I
haven't seen bones at all yet but
everyone I know has raved about it when
you were making the film um did you
realize it was going to be something
special I did 12 special because the
script was amazing and because the
actors were just Sublime and America is
a very beautiful place listen man I'm
I'm really happy that everything is
going really well for you and um and
I've said this to you before and I'll
say it again
um not to specifically talk about one
thing but I I still think call me by
your name was the best film of that year
uh I think that's a masterpiece that
will be remembered for thank you for a
long time you know thank you you're very
kind thank you so much
um listen have a fantastic day and I
really am so happy to talk to you again
likewise